[Musica]
amedeo modigliani diceva che è la vita è
un dono dei pochi e molti di coloro che
sanno e danno a coloro che non sanno è
che non hanno che cos'è l'arte se non
dono se non condivisione di esperienze
di emozioni di bellezza che cosa ci
insegnano la musica il teatro la danza
la pittura ed ogni forma d'arte
conosciuta se non la bellezza del dono
sin dall'inizio di questo periodo
surreale che stiamo vivendo sin
dall'inizio della pandemia
i primi ad utilizzare la rete per
condividere bellezza sono stati proprio
gli artisti e così musicisti cantanti
poeti attori danzatori hanno condiviso e
quindi donato pezzi di storia e nuove
emozioni la vita è un dono dei pochi e
molti di coloro che sanno e danno a
coloro che non sanno è che non hanno
sono le parole di un artista talentuoso
appassionato fisicamente fragile ma dal
carisma dirompente potentissimo e la
fragilità e vera e quindi la fragilità è
forte così un po di tempo fa devo dire
che in realtà sono trascorsi ben più di
dieci anni ho scelto di fare della mia
più grande passione la mia professione
ho scelto di occuparmi di raccolta fondi
e comunicazione al fianco delle non
profit al fianco delle fragilità e l'ho
fatto dopo anni di impegno in
associazionismo e volontariato
sapete quando parlo alle persone
professione
l'ottanta per cento di loro mi guarda
come se fossi una creatura aliena un
animale estinto o comunque un animale
via d'estinzione
io sono una fan razer è una
comunicatrice sociale vivo in sicilia
dove operano prevalentemente e qui anche
tra chi ha compreso di cosa mi occupi
c'è chi pensa che il mio non sia un vero
lavoro o che a fare ciò che faccio non
ci voglia poi tanta tanta fatica
sono tempi difficili ma sono tempi di
cambiamento sono tempi in cui qualcosa
di importante si muove
e sono proprio i semi che lo stesso non
profit ha generato che stanno crescendo
davanti a noi io questi semi li ho
riconosciuti via
innaffiati accuditi ogni giorno certa
che ciò che faccio abbia un significato
e che questo sia un significato
importante vorrei oggi potervi fornire
agli strumenti per comprendere che
generare un cambiamento
costa fatica
alle volte consentitemelo anche una
buona dose di sofferenza capacità di
adattamento tantissima ma generare un
cambiamento
che porti beneficio ad altri oltre che a
se stessi e l'unico modo per fare andare
più velocemente e meglio le cose so che
parlare di questi temi può farmi
sembrare banale superficiale e proprio
per questo motivo ho pensato di
condividere con voi dei dati che tra
l'altro sono stati recentemente diffusi
dall'istat che possono farvi comprendere
con più facilità ciò di cui sto parlando
il no profit è cresciuto cresce le
istituzioni del non profit sono
cresciute dai dati istat sapete cosa si
scopre ad esempio voi sapevate che il
più del 27 per cento delle istituzioni
non profit
operano nel sud italia e nelle isole
un altro dato interessante è il numero
dei dipendenti è il no profit il 19 per
cento opera nel sud italia il dato più
interessante riguarda propri dipendenti
perché è un numero che cresce e cresce
considerevolmente
pensate che nel
2011 erano oltre 400 88 mila dipendenti
del proprio profit e in otto anni dal
2011 al 2019 questo numero è
praticamente raddoppiato così come è
evidente che anche le istituzioni stanno
aumentando e crescendo questi dati per
chi come me lavora in questo settore
ma a tutti confermano una cosa
abbastanza evidente che non profit
operosissimo in italia colmate le lacune
degli spazi a cui nessuno pensa e se non
se ne occupasse il no profit questo
significherebbe privare migliaia di
persone di servizi fondamentali
ma non è solo questo che questi dati
restituiscono infatti il no profit può
rappresentare un volano per la crescita
economica del nostro del nostro paese
può rappresentare un'opportunità
per
favorire nuovi sbocchi professionali
ma c'è un'altra cosa che è chiara che se
il non profit vuole crescere e
migliorarsi così come sta facendo in
questi anni deve pianificare in modo più
strutturato la sua crescita smettendola
di versare che tutto nel no profit debba
essere generato unicamente da un impegno
volontario in sostanza il no profit ha
bisogno di essere
affiancato da professionisti e proprio
facendovi questa riflessione che proverò
a rispondere alla domanda che oggi mi è
stata fatta mi è stato chiesto se per
generare un cambiamento io ritenga più
dire una rivoluzione o un'evoluzione
bene io chiarisco fin da subito che non
ho una risposta certa se non l'ha
maturata consapevolezza che alcuna
rivoluzione potrà avere luogo se i suoi
autori non comprenderanno come
necessaria e non considereranno
necessarie alla propria evoluzione e poi
quando mi è stata posta questa domanda
in realtà me ne sono fatta un altra
chiedere se pensiamo a una rivoluzione o
una evoluzione è come dare per scontato
che un cambiamento lo si voglia e o un
cambiamento lo desidero sia chiaro è
abbastanza evidente dal mestiere che
faccio ma siamo certi che tutti intorno
a noi un cambiamento lo desiderino
davvero lo vogliano e che vogliono che
questo cambiamento sia tangibile
effettivo reale
perdonatemi ma io vivo in un territorio
la sicilia che mi ha abituata a queste
amare considerazioni però posso dirgli
che mi è capitato mi è capitato di
operare di fare il mio lavoro e di avere
accanto a me persone che non credevano
nel cambiamento che stavo provando a
generare ma nel momento stesso in cui
compreso di avere l'opportunità di
rendere possibili tangibili progetti che
potevano affiancare aiutare e sostenere
altre persone non ha avuto un solo
istante di esitazione e sono stata
sempre più convinta della scelta che
avevo ed ho fatto
del resto io amo parlare di dono il dono
e attenzione ad una storia nasce
dall'attenzione verso un racconto è una
storia che vuole cambiare e una causa
che riesce a costruire dei risultati
ed è proprio in un momento come quello
che stiamo vivendo che dovremmo dare
grande attenzione alla storia che stiamo
scrivendo
perché la storia di questo periodo ci
impone di osservarci e di ascoltarci ci
impone di guardare dentro noi stessi per
comprendere meglio l'art l'altro per
comprendere ciò che abbiamo intorno
e la storia spesso scrive gli stessi
finali dolorosi
ingiustificati e ingiustificabili
e la storia spesso iscritto alla chi
resta e quindi sono le mani di chi
spesso agisce con violenza con codardia
o da chi cambia tutto e si affanna
perché poi tutto resta esattamente
immobile ecco io credo che ci siano
anche a tante persone che scrivono la
storia augurandosi che cambino i
risultati e che non si ripetano
sempre gli stessi
gli stessi errori
il dono ci ricorda ciò che abbiamo è
vero ma ci ricorda anche ciò che
possiamo diventare ci fa comprendere che
esistono esigenze diverse dalle nostre
ci ricorda che un evoluzione è
necessaria e per alcuni ciò avviene
riscoprendo una capacità di osare per
altri
quella di la capacità di resistere di
resistere alle intemperie e questo
nonostante tutto anche quando il
territorio in cui operiamo sembra un
l'arci contro che siamo solo dei
sognatori
ecco in genere chi ci dava il sognatore
e chi urla o peggio che bisbiglia che il
cambiamento non è mai una cosa buona
io
sono venuta qui a dirvi che credo
fermamente in un cambiamento perché
credo che sia possibile
costruire progetti che siano utili per
tutti attraverso il sostegno di molti è
che questo possa essere fatto divulgando
messaggi che fanno la differenza perché
vedete
nonostante noi esseri umani si faccia
tutto per agire con egoismo non possiamo
fare a meno che ascoltarci e supportarci
perché non è una storiella che ci
raccontano da bambini da soli non si va
da nessuna parte se non qui su questa
terra dove siamo e di cui tutti dovremmo
prenderci cura un po di più
io voglio generare un cambiamento perché
credo che le parole siano importanti ma
credo anche che a queste debbano sempre
seguire i fatti
ecco perché il racconto di una mission
assume valore perché una causa genera
valore
perché affianca l'operato di persone al
fianco di altre persone
perché
il racconto può aiutare può sostenere
chi legge o ascolta a comprendere le
necessità
a sentire i bisogni di chi deve e può
essere aiutato e sostenuto perché del
resto il dolore esisterà sempre e chi lo
riconosce deve ricordarsi di quanto sia
gratificante
evitarlo agli altri
io a un certo punto della mia vita
questa cosa l'ho compresa ne ho sentito
in qualche modo la responsabilità quindi
non ho solo shell un po più di dieci
anni fa come vi dicevo il mio percorso
professionale
ma ho anche scelto la mia causa
ho scelto di dedicare tempo alla
promozione della cultura del dono e ho
scelto di farlo proprio iniziando da qui
dalla sicilia dal luogo in cui io abito
ed opero e ho scelto questa causa
quando ho avuto modo di confrontarmi con
colleghi che facevano al mio stesso
mestiere ma più che altro avevano fatto
le mie stesse scelte per ragioni molto
simili e ho incontrato l'associazione
italiana fundraiser
lì sì ho potuto confrontarmi con
fundraiser provenienti da tutta italia
ho potuto farmi
contagiare da un agorà di professionisti
e anche da professionisti provenienti da
altri paesi paesi in cui il valore di
queste professionalità e molto più
evidente di quanto non sia in italia
conosciuto e riconosciuto
creatività competenza intelligenze al
fianco del non profit e badate bene
chi fa questa professione
alle sue spalle percorsi molto
differenti tra loro
hanno alle loro spalle professioni
differenti ci sono fundraiser che
vengono dal mondo del profit ma hanno
tutti una cosa in comune tutti i
fundraiser che ho conosciuto hanno una
cosa in comune tutti hanno una gran
voglia di cambiare in meglio almeno un
pezzetto di mondo ma immaginate quanto
possa essere gratificante almeno
provarci a cambiare un pezzetto di mondo
io do grande valore ha questo a questo
pezzetto
cercare e trovare
altri fundraiser altri comunicatori
sociali nel territorio in cui vivo in
sicilia è stata è stato veramente
difficile
e questa è la parte del racconto cui vi
chiedo di prestare grande attenzione
ci sono
pochissimi sono troppo pochi i
professionisti del dono in italia sono
troppo pochi professionisti nel campo
del fundraising della comunicazione
sociale nel sud italia sono un numero
ancora inferiore rispetto alla media
nazionale eppure
ci sono migliaia di enti del terzo
settore che con generosità
lungimiranza operano ogni giorno
fornendo migliaia di servizi anche in
questo triangolo di terra pieno di
storia e di cultura abbracciato dal
mediterraneo che la sicilia questo cosa
significa
significa che c'è tantissimo da fare è
che il fundraising così come altre
professionalità che possono supportare
il non profit sono tutte opportunità da
cogliere
sono tutte opportunità da cogliere in
questo pezzetto di mondo così come in
tutto il paese
ci sono delle esperienze nella vita dei
moventi che segnano il nostro tempo che
segnano il percorso delle nostre
giornate dei nostri mesi dei nostri anni
io sono fortunata perché il dono ha
sempre fatto parte integrante
dell'educazione che ho ricevuto da
bambina e sin da bambina ecco credo che
un'evoluzione debba partire proprio da
questo
dall'educazione
dal desiderio di comprendere ciò che chi
più giusto possa essere generato
guardando a noi stessi sì ma come
risorsa per la comunità come risorsa
utile e preziosa per la nostra comunità
quindi un evoluzione
e necessaria è del caso di dirlo
nonostante tutto
nonostante il contesto in cui operiamo
sempre volerci tatuare addosso il nome
di sognatori bene sapete che vi dico
cominciamo a rispondere che siamo dei
visionari
anticipiamo i risultati della nostra
evoluzione programmiamo una rivoluzione
facciamo in modo che tutti possano farne
parte i visionari sono generatori di
cambiamento non si limitano a sognare il
futuro assolutamente si attivano e fanno
in modo di coinvolgere ogni risorsa e
tutto ciò che hanno intorno perché il
futuro arrivi oggi
ricordate cosa diceva modigliani
la vita è un dono
dei pochi ai molti di coloro che sanno e
danno a coloro che non sanno è che non
hanno queste parole per me rappresentano
la chiave che apre la porta alle più
grandi gratificazioni
quello che diceva modigliani oggi e
visionario ma è la chiave per l'unica
rivoluzione necessaria una rivoluzione
fatta di evoluzione di onestà di
equilibrio
infine c'è qualcosa
che possiamo fare tutti c'è un dono che
possiamo tutti farci rendono che
dovremmo farci tutti più spesso
non consentire mai
al dolore
alla disperazione
alla rabbia ai silenzi alla violenza di
silenzi di spendere il nostro entusiasmo
dobbiamo piuttosto farne parte di
rivoluzione costruire un busta dico che
rappresenti esso stesso un dono un
mosaico di esperienze che ci ricordi che
con curiosità coraggio e cuore possiamo
essere più vicini al mondo possiamo
guardarlo con occhi diversi che sono gli
occhi di chi sa ascoltare di chi sa
esserci per l'altro nonostante tutto
sono gli occhi di chi si consente il
privilegio di emozionarsi con coraggio e
l'arte del dono grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]